[Applause]
thank you your highness may I now invite
the president of the European commission
for her remarks please
your highnesses excellencies it's been
two years since we launched pgii a joint
Vision by the world's leading economies
to invest in the infrastructure that low
and middle-income countries need
and two years on more large-scale
projects are seeing the light and we are
presenting two of them today
first the India middle east Europe
economic Corridor this is nothing but
historic
it will be the most direct connection to
date between India the Arabian Gulf and
Europe
with a rail link that will make trade
between India and Europe 40 faster
with an electricity cable and a clean
hydrogen pipeline to Foster clean energy
trade between Asia the Middle East and
Europe
with a high-speed data cable to link
some of the most Innovative digital
ecosystems in the world and create
business opportunities all along the way
these are state-of-the-art connections
for the World of Tomorrow faster shorter
cleaner
this Corridor is much more than just a
railway or cable
it is a green and digital Bridge across
continents and civilizations
and this is also the spirit of the
second project we announced today
the trans-african corridor
which will connect the port of lobito in
Angola
with the katanga province in DRC
and the copper belt in Zambia
our goal is not only to connect a
landlocked region to the Sea
our partnership will also invest in
local value chains in clean energy and
in skills for the local Workforce
this is the spirit of pgii it is a whole
new approach to large infrastructure
investment
it is about shared prosperity
it is about real benefits for all
Partners thank you
thank you